hey guys welcome back to part three of
this series of web scraping with r
in the last video we kept working on our
imdb web scraping and we got all the
cast members
i'll just show you real quick we have
the original four columns from the first
video we had this new column with the
cast members that we got by going into
each of the pages
i'd recommend checking out those two
videos if you haven't already because
we're going to build on that yet again
with
uh this new tutorial where we're going
into multiple pages how do we scrape
multiple pages of results
so
again
we're going to be using imdb
and the first step is to figure out how
the url of the website is changing
so in order to scrape multiple pages you
can see that if we go down the very
bottom we go to next
this little text right here will appear
that says start equals 51
and if we go to the next page
that goes to 101 so sometimes it'll say
you'll be on a website and it'll be like
slash page equals one slash page equals
two slash page equals three and so on
and in that case it's pretty easy here
you can see
it's incrementing by 50 each time
because it's showing us all the results
on the page
and if we
go back to that very first page we can
go back twice you can see that there's
no number you'd expect it to say one
but
we can kind of
trick it into
doing that
and showing us the first result which is
actually going to be super useful for
this tutorial
so we figured out how the url changes
and essentially what we're going to do
is make a for loop that will
go through each of the pages we want to
scrape then just do everything that we
did before so not super hard but there
are a few components to it
so we figured out how the url changes we
can copy this new link
which is going to be slightly different
than this previous link because it
includes the
page the result number that we're on
so we will comment that out
uh actually we can just get rid of it
cool
uh and then we just need to create a big
for loop outside of everything and i
know i said in the last video that
like the supply function or l apply
function is more preferable to for loops
but i mean for this situation it just
kind of makes sense for me to use a for
loop
but you can totally do it the way that
you feel most comfortable
so i'll create a for loop and we'll
create a variable called page result
so this needs to go from 1 to 50 to
1 or sorry 1 to 51 to 101 to 151 and so
on and so forth
and you could
make a character vector or rather a
numeric vector
that is literally you typing out manual
stuff but if you want to give it to like
a thousand and one
you would spend a lot of effort doing
that so instead
i'm gonna use the sequence command and
i'll go from one
to uh i could make this a thousand and
one and it would give us
a lot of pages but just for the sake of
the video i'm just going to do the first
two pages so 251
and by 50.
and if we just run that
you can see that the output is 151 and
let's say this this was a thousand and
one
that would give us the corresponding
results that we need
but let's just do 51 for the video
and
add our braces
and then essentially we can put
everything
inside the for loop but
let's first get the link back
so we have that that new link
uh that has this start equals one
but
we actually need to
make sure that that link is changing as
each page result goes
uh as it increases
so we're gonna use the paste command
again here
and we're gonna paste back in that link
and then we're gonna get rid of the one
add some quotes to separate these guys
out
and then in between
the the equals and then the next
ampersand
we're going to add age result
so let me make it so you guys can see
that
just like that and we know that paste by
default
adds space between all the text and we'd
have to add this sep equals quotes uh
alternatively you can just use the paste
zero command which by default will
get rid of spaces between the strings
that you're trying to concatenate
cool so we got our link
now
we can copy over or cut over our page
because that's the same and
essentially all of this stuff is also
going to be exactly the same
so no need to change that
we can just put that right there
now get cast this function we could put
it in the loop
um except it would just be it's just it
doesn't change each time it's just one
function
so we're going to move that outside the
loop so it doesn't re-run each time
and we do want to keep our cast
we want to keep that column
but we
also want to keep our movies now the
issue here
is
uh movies
is set to a data frame and every single
time this loop runs it'll reset movies
so
right now if i were to run all this code
and i output movies it would actually
only output the last
uh the last 50 results so the second
page of movies
that's not exactly what we want we're
going to need to
create a
movies
data frame that'll just be empty
and then instead of overwriting it each
time by strictly setting it equal to a
data frame
we're going to use the r bind function
which means row bind and it'll take
first argument will be movies
and the second argument will actually
stay this data frame
so now each time this this uh for loop
runs
it'll take whatever the old movies
variable was and then
just
put on the new rows of movies that it
got from this new page that it's running
on
so that's really about it
the last thing i'm going to add is
just a print statement at the end here
and this is solely for the purpose of
tracking progress i mean i mentioned in
the last video how
the cast
cast command cast function that we're
doing it takes some time to run because
it's going into every single one of
these movies and figuring out who the
cast members are
so you might be wondering like if your
code's running for 20 minutes
if it's like actually running or if it
just got stuck on something so having a
print is really good just printing the
page results is good enough so i'll go
ahead and run this
and hopefully it works
it should actually take some time to run
but i'll come back when that's finished
and we can see what it looks like
awesome so my code finished running it
just took a couple minutes not too bad
let's go check out
what our movies data frame looks like
and hopefully we have more than 50
results
looks like we do let's just confirm that
this is actually movies from the second
page
yep jurassic park is 51
and looks like that looks good
yeah awesome so we have 100 results
that's from the first two pages of imdb
or from whatever this these movies are
um
it's really easy to change this to do
multiple pages if i wanted to literally
go to
like all 1070 titles it wouldn't be
super hard to do
i just need to edit this too
but that's about it for this video so
thanks so much for watching and uh again
i'll probably have another video for
whatever the next part is i think it's
gonna be on
scraping tables with arvest so hopefully
i'll see you there thanks for watching
[Music]
you